you
why did you feel the need to get us
suited up in this space man armor
because I ended the first time I rode
the optical hi I was taking it down a
hill and I flipped right over the
handlebars and landed on my ass I didn't
really feel the need to wear anything
more than a helmet okay I i think the
bike had a lot of a lot of torque I mean
it's an electric you know it's electric
motor right you know it's an 801 motor
so you're gonna get up there pretty
quickly yeah so you will ride this the
other day but I didn't traffic yeah and
I don't you know on a flat surface you
kind of feel like it bucks a little bit
but I don't know I don't really I don't
necessarily feel the need to to be
suited up like this so Steven this bike
is at what ninety thousand dollars yes
that's more than my trust fund that I
don't have why would I buy this bike
instead of like a motorcycle like a
kawasaki ninja which costs about the
same and goes ten times as fast ok I
have really really good answers for this
answer number one here's the situation
you cannot ride a kawasaki ninja in the
bike lane it doesn't really belong in
the street but it's technically
street-legal because actually without
pedaling it'll only go 20 miles an hour
and get up to 35 miles an hour really
pumping and pedaling you can take it out
in the back roads you can do dirt biking
you can do city riding which is the bulk
of what we did
yeah and you just plug it in and you
know you're basically ready to go on a
full charge you can get about two hours
or so depending on if you're in fast
motor eco mode you don't think that
that's worth nine thousand dollars no no
definitely not so let's talk about this
the specs on the bike a little bit so
let's do that it's got its got a
motorized bumps under 800 watt motor
lithium-ion battery avid disc brakes
it's got Fox shock do the fock shots are
awesome yeah awesome yeah the most
upsetting part about this whole gear
situation is that does not
actually make a cape oh I'm gonna
honestly give this thing nine out of ten
balls at least in terms of the fun
factor I don't know if I had nine
thousand dollars of income in this
economy if I would drop it on a nine
thousand dollar bike but it's super fun
you'll totally enjoy the experience
whether you're you know cruising through
the streets are on the back roads it's
definitely cooler than a Segway yeah oh
my god was in a sec yeah you'll get beat
up far less yeah where are we where are
we dressed like Power Rangers
you